ya hemos logrado un buen progreso en la
deducción de las distintas partes de la
transformación de lorentz de hecho
logramos expresar a x prima en términos
del factor de lawrence gama x b y te
verdad y de hecho también lo logramos al
revés verdad pudimos expresar a x en
términos de gamma el factor de laurent x
prima de y t prima verdad y de hecho
logramos deducir también quién era el
factor de lawrence gamma verdad gamma es
igual a 1 entre la raíz de 1 b cuadrada
sobre c cuadrada y ahora lo único que
nos falta es expresar a t prima en
términos de x y de t verdad la pregunta
es cómo hacerlo y la forma en la que lo
haré será tomar esta ecuación que
tenemos aquí verdad y voy a tratar de
despejar t prima
luego las partes que tengan x prima pues
las voy a sustituir simplemente con esta
expresión que ya tenemos para x prima
así que vamos
y hacerlo muy bien vamos a hacerlo de
aquí vamos a partir de esta expresión
vamos a dividir de ambos lados entre
gamma muy bien entonces lo que tenemos
es x que lo dividimos entre gamma será
igual será igual a lo que tenemos del
lado derecho pero cancelando gamma
verdad será x prima más
por de prima
por prima ahí lo tenemos ahora qué es lo
que vamos a hacer restamos de ambos
lados x prima verdad entonces tenemos x
dividido entre gamma luego restamos x
prima y esto será igual
por mi prima vamos bien hasta ahí muy
bien ahora qué es lo que tenemos que
hacer para despejar a t prima pues
tenemos que dividir en ambos lados entre
b muy bien entonces qué es lo que vamos
a obtener vamos a obtener x dividido
entre gamma por b verdad aquí ya estamos
dividiendo entre b
- x prima dividido entre entre b esto
será igual a t prima muy bien ahí
tenemos ya t prima verdad ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es tomar esta
expresión para x prima y sustituirla en
este valor verdad porque aquí aparece x
prima simplemente sustituimos con esta
expresión para x prima muy bien entonces
que es lo que vamos a tener
tendremos que prima lo voy a pasar solo
de este de este lado será igual a x
dividido entre gamma gamma x
menos
- aquí vamos a sustituir x prima verdad
que en este caso será gamma que
multiplica a x menos menos deporte
muy bien aquí está la expresión para x
prima y esto va / va dividido entre b
dividido entre b ahí lo tenemos este es
ya otra expresión para t prima lo que
voy a hacer aquí es factorizar gamma muy
bien entonces vamos a factorizar gamma y
entonces este prima será igual a gamma
que multiplica a vamos a ver
x dividido entre aquí tenemos que poner
gamma cuadrada verdad para que al
multiplicar o al poner gama entre gamma
cuadrada sólo nos dé gamma verdad en el
denominador y esto va multiplicando por
ver simplemente hace esta multiplicación
gamma por x entre gamma cuadrada de es
justamente este término que tenemos aquí
y luego tenemos menos gamma ya está
factor izado y tendremos
de hecho vamos a distribuir el menos y
vamos a distribuir la división entre b
entonces tendremos menos x dividido
entre b
/ b y luego tenemos menos por menos es
más aquí vamos a tener más b t dividido
entre b que es simplemente te muy bien
aquí tenemos esta expresión de prima y
ahora vamos a vamos a fijarnos en una
parte de esta expresión vamos a fijarnos
sólo en esta parte y vamos a ver qué es
lo que obtenemos vamos a ver vamos a
tratar de simplificar esta parte muy
bien entonces por ejemplo aquí podemos
simplemente factorizar x verdad factor
izamos x y aquí multiplica a 1 entre
gamma cuadrada por b 1 / gamma cuadrada
x
por ver menos
voy a dejarlo con ese color menos
1 sobre b 1 sobre b muy bien entonces
esta es digamos este cuadrito verde
simplemente lo resto se puede reescribir
de esta forma y para hacer esta esta
diferencia de fracciones pues
necesitamos encontrar un denominador
común verdad para poder para poder
hacerlo entonces vamos a poner aquí gama
cuadrada y acá arriba pondremos también
gama cuadrada verdad así esta es la
misma expresión que teníamos
anteriormente pero ahora ganamos que
este denominador es exactamente el mismo
que el del otro término verdad entonces
veamos cómo podríamos hacer esto esto de
aquí simplemente lo vamos a simplificar
verdad sería 1
- gama cuadrada 1 - gama cuadrada y todo
esto va dividido entre gama cuadrada por
ver gama cuadrada por b vamos bien y
esto será igual vamos a ver pues lo que
podemos hacer aquí es sustituir quienes
gama cuadrada verdad y en realidad gama
cuadrada es muy fácil de calcular aquí
de hecho tenemos gama entonces gama
cuadrada será elevada al cuadrado tanto
número numerador perdón como denominador
1 al cuadrado es 1 y el cuadrado de esto
pues es simplemente lo que tenemos
dentro de la raíz verdad es uno menos de
cuadrada sobre se cuadrada de hecho lo
voy a hacer un poco más más justo para
que pueda escribir otra expresión gama
cuadrada es 1 entre 1 - b cuadrada sobre
se cuadrada verdad y esto si
multiplicamos por se cuadrada tanto el
numerador como el denominador tendremos
tendremos se cuadrada menos de cuadrada
entonces esta expresión es la que vamos
a usar para poder simplificar esta otra
que tenemos aquí verdad entonces quien
sería uno bueno uno sería se cuadrada
menos b cuadrada dividido entre pse
cuadrada menos b cuadrada esto
claramente es uno y luego restamos gamma
cuadrada verdad préstamos gamma cuadrada
que será se cuadrada dividido entre pse
cuadrada menos de cuadrada entonces esta
forma de expresar a uno es conveniente
porque otra vez tenemos un denominador
común verdad y luego todo esto va
dividido entre gama cuadrada gama
cuadrada que será se cuadrada entre pse
cuadrada menos b cuadrada por b por b
entonces aquí multiplicamos por b muy
bien entonces qué es lo que vamos a
obtener bueno aquí simplemente podríamos
simplificar verdad porque tendremos se
cuadrada menos e cuadrada esto sé
la verdad y entonces tendremos vamos a
escribir lo menos de cuadrada dividido
entre pse cuadrada menos be cuadrada y
luego esta división es exactamente lo
mismo que si multiplicamos por el
recíproco de lo que tenemos acá abajo
verdad entonces será se cuadrada menos b
cuadrada dividido entre pse cuadrada por
b y entonces lo que podemos ver es que
otra vez podemos simplificar esta verdad
aquí tenemos este factor en el
denominador ese mismo factor en el
numerador verdad y entonces esto será
igual simplemente a también podríamos
simplificar una vez verdad porque aquí
tenemos una b en el denominador y
tenemos dos veces en el numerador como
un factor es entonces podemos cancelar
uno y lo que obtenemos simplemente es
menos b dividido entre
cuadrada muy bien entonces con esto ya
podemos expresar bien a t prima verdad
porque esto de aquí es simplemente hay
que multiplicarlo por equis y luego
sustituirlo acá verdad entonces lo que
tenemos de t prima es que esto será
igual a gamma gamma que multiplica a
nuestro cuadrito el cuadrito era x que
multiplica a o quizás deberíamos mejor
poner el otro sumando primero vamos a
poner primero t y luego tendremos menos
bs cuadrada
- de se cuadrada por equis verdad todo
esto es esto que tenemos aquí y que era
este cuadrito verde muy bien ahí tenemos
nuestra expresión para t prima ya hemos
terminado hemos completado nuestras
transformaciones del ourense en realidad
por ejemplo comenzamos con estas dos
expresiones de aquí arriba que de hecho
trabajamos en los vídeos anteriores y
después de muchas operaciones
algebraicas quizás digamos un tanto
peliagudas obtuvimos esta expresión de
prima será igual a gamma por t menos b
sobre se cuadrada por equis y hemos
terminado